- We always like to close out
with something to give
you all the good vibes.
That's just how we do y'all.
This is "What I'm liking."
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
As you know, we just finished
up an amazing road trip.
That's where I got to meet Mikayla.
Now I want to tell you
about Tamara and Brandy,
moms and besties from Winterset, Iowa.
For the past few years,
they've set out on an annual girl's trip,
camping, hiking,
checking out sites off the
beaten path kind of vibe.
This year they made their
journey extra memorable
simply by giving their servers
along the way ginormous tips,
which is cool.
We have these ladies on the line
watching on KCCI, Des Moines
now airing at 4:00 PM.
It's so great to have you both here.
(audience applauding)
- Hi!
- [Kelly] Hi.
So this is so cool,
coming from a previous server,
I was a server,
I know that all these
people appreciated it.
How'd you come up with this idea?
- Well, every year
Brandy and I take a trip
and we went on our first
one to Northeast Iowa.
We visited 13 waterfalls,
we traveled 26 hours, 1300 miles
in one weekend,
but had such a great time.
The next year we went to Nebraska,
the next year we decided to
head up to the U.P in Michigan.
And then finally this last
year we went to Illinois.
And we've both been servers before, too.
Things don't always come
easy and we just decided
why not try to help
change someone's lives?
So we painted this Venmo account
on the back of our car
and opened a Facebook
page and it exploded.
(Tamara chuckles)
- I love that.
So wait, how did this servers react?
- [Brandy] Well, they
would bring us our bill
and we would fill it out
and then we would flag them down
and say, "Hey we would like to
talk to you about our bill."
And they would come over
and just instantly be like,
"What? What is wrong?"
And then they look at the
bill and they're like, "Whoa!
What is going on here?" (chuckles)
- [Tamara] Yeah, in our fourth night
our server was a woman working four jobs
trying to put herself through college.
She was wanting to be a math
teacher and I'm a math teacher
so it's near and dear to my heart.
And so we gave her $985
and then on top of that
we surprised her with
$1000 worth of gift cards.
And then the tears started falling.
- For all of us.
- Yes.
(Tamara chuckles)
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I know!
I've seen the video and
I still cry every time.
'Cause you just don't know how people
you know, where they are in their lives
and it can be really helpful
and it can turn things around.
So it's a beautiful thing that
y'all are doing for people
and you know, you've been servers,
so you know it can be rough out there.
But thank you so much, Tamara,
thank you so much, Brandy.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(phone chimes)
(audience applauds)
- [Tamara] Thank you, Kelly.
- [Brandy] Thank you.
- [Kelly] And that's not all,
our season long partner,
Pilot pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to honor truly unstoppable
and truly kind people just like y'all.
So, they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1000
that you can use for your next road trip.
Peem-peem-pee!
- Oh my God! That's so generous.
- [Kelly] Hey, keep
spreading that kindness,
it really does, it makes
big ripples in the pond.
So thank you so much, ladies.
Have a blessed night.
(audience applauding)
Thank you to all our guests today,
Elisabeth Moss, Noah
Cyrus, Mikayla Diante.
Y'all have a great day
and if it's not well, try and change it.